Computational Biology is an emerging field that's going to be big.
>> Now just like computer science and coding is becoming really important
for all different professions nowadays. It's
even more needed in biology and genetics.
>> I mean it takes a lot of computation and
analysis to sequence a whole genome. And, and the processing power
it takes is immense. Not to mention other changes in the
medical field, like digitizing of patient medical records, and a lot
of other things.
>> Now, if any of you out there are
interested in computer science coding and biology. There's a
whole field waiting for you. There's a lot of
companies out there that are looking for good computational biologists.